hey well Karen we can officially say we
can have our cake and eat it too that's
right it was really sage listen guys we
have this incredible recipe this is to
die for if you like cake comment below
that you do like cake because you will
love this cake yeah what's a call Karen
it's a coconut pecan cake cheeto coconut
okay cute Oh Nico coconut coconut pecan
pecan okay try to say that 5 times real
fast right or if twice the person that
our friend actually made this and I got
permission to share it with you it's
incredible you're gonna love this so if
you do like cake and you want to dessert
at the end of the meal not as a snack
then this is what you want to do and the
question is like what are you gonna use
what were you gonna eat since this is
mine
you funny you're funny
okay good yeah this actually as far as
cakes go was very straightforward cake
recipe um you know mix the dry
ingredients mix wet ingredients mix them
together little toasting of the coconut
and become and anything takes the cake
I'm gonna sample it go ahead okay I'll
just say this if this is really any good
my only question
oh that's too big of a bite hmm my only
question is is it too sweet
hmm Wow mmm not too sweet no it's
probably because I like pecans I should
have to mention my mouth but it's a
light cake but it's got a lot it's got
substance so it's I don't I don't think
it's a dry cake but it's got almond and
coconut flour in it and that actually um
kind of pulls in whatever this sweetness
is of the frosting the thing that makes
it good
is the fluffiness of the cake itself
right it's fluffy it's fluffy because
with Kido you got almond flour it's
really hard so this this is a very
unique recipe in that you'll see if you
actually read the ingredients and the
directions there's certain techniques
that you're gonna to mix this with that
to make it really fluffy you're just
gonna beat the egg whites and fold them
in separate but and what about the egg
yolks was they going complicated we were
saying he never heard of that before so
he thought it was like wow that's really
high-tech but um it's pretty common if
you're if you're into baking so it's
really not hard at all and it's very
tasty I think it looks really pretty
it's beautiful
which is important so the whole thing
but I won't that's right we have to save
some for the kids
we'll save one piece I can share okay
guys so your cake recipe or keto coconut
pecan cake recipe is waiting for you
okay check it out now yeah bye enjoy
[Music]